How to get the call?
Hey, Ryan, hey Tom.
Ryan, hit home.
I gave any Manish.
Well, guys, how we doing? How we doing?
Good, good, good, good. I see new wallpaper. That's nice.
Where's the data center one? I'm missing the data center one.
That looks...
Are you talking to me yet, Kevin?
Gary.
Kam.
No, I think mine.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I could.
Data center one, for some reason, that's like, I don't know where it's at, so I'm gonna have to dig deep for it.
Come on, Ryan. You should get it from Chris. You should get it from Chris.
Off the bottom about it.
Yeah.
It looks, it's amazing. Anyways, talking about Kris, Tom, will he join? Is he busy, as always?
Ohh.
I don't see why not, but he didn't reach out tonight. I mean, I guess we could start if he's not on.
How about David? I don't want to start this meeting without David. Look who's here. David, I was talking about you, man.
Yeah.
They do.
Speak of the devil.
Speak of the devil, there he is.
There's the data center.
There, you're speaking on mute. Yeah, there's the data center. There you go.
David, you're speaking on mute; we are not able to hear you.
I just want you to fill in the gaps.
The little ad-libbing thing.
All right.
Team building.
See building, right? Absolutely.
But I have the camera on this time. Usually it's the other way around. Camera off you.
I appreciate it, David. You know it. I like to see your beautiful eyes, so that's the reason. Likewise. Hey, Kris, so Ryan, Ryan, you have two wallpapers with Data Center. See?
Good, good to see you. Good to see you.
Hey, Kris.
Yeah, I'll let the...
Yeah.
I'll have to have him send me over so I can switch it.
Okay, who are we missing? Curtis, not sure.
I think he, I don't, I think he's out of the office.
He's PTO, yeah, yeah, he's out of the office today.
Ohh.
Okay, and how about New Mexico team? I don't see anyone from New Mexico.
Ah.
Who do you have on there, Kevin, for New Mexico, for that?
Don't know about those guys.
New Mexico after Brian, it was...
James.
Okay.
No, it's Pat. Pat. I think it's Pat. Pat. Yeah.
Yeah, I was just wondering if, okay, I was just making sure you knew, yeah, Bryan is no longer with him, so yeah, I'm not sure. Okay.
Yes, yes.
I think he handed over his responsibilities to Pat.
Yeah.
I'm not sure on that one either, so...
Oh, okay. Okay, anyways, I mean, if they do join, they'll be great. Otherwise, we'll send the presentation, they can review it.
Just.
Sounds good.
All right, so let me share my screen and we will go through the presentation.
I hope you can see it.
That's good.
All right, ladies and gentlemen, welcome to our monthly service review for ITBD Solutions. We will be looking at April month's performance. The agenda item remains pretty much the same. We'll go through highlights, performance analysis, and user sentiments, US holiday schedule, AI by design,
It.
Way forward and then meeting minutes.
Yeah.
Getting to the highlights part, Nathan completed his network training. Stellum continues to shine on RMW account with policy reviews from the end users. ITBD teams average billable reached at 73% in April, and TTR was at 83%. Ralph and Kyle continues to provide.
You.
Yeah.
great business support over the weekends. So these are the few highlights from last month. Before we get into the next slide, anyone who would like to add to this?
Nope.
Okay, we can get into the performance analysis piece. April for New Mexico, I think due to low ticket count, the billable was less. Apart from that, everyone else did great. Nathan, 75%, Stellan, Nixon, 89% each, Ralph, Kyle, 67, 53.
You.
No.
Lewis, St. Louis Rico was around 63%, Matthew was at 80%. So that's the April month's performance.
That's great, we have Larry.
Larry, thank you so much for joining in.
Good afternoon, everybody. Sorry I'm late.
Kaila.
No worries, Larry. I hope we hope you're doing well.
Yes, yes, you as well. Thank you for asking.
Welcome. I hope you don't, you're not missing Lee, by the way. He's not on this bridge right now.
No, I never miss Lee.
I...
Yeah.
He keep on, he keep on bugging you, right?
Hey.
Yeah.
He's a good guy.
He is, he is. Thank you. All right, so we were discussing a billable piece over here, Larry, just to fill you in. And I'm just going around the table to see if anyone has any questions regarding billable utilization.
Yeah.
Mmh.
K, I...
Silence is consensus, so I'm gonna move on.
The.
Okay, ticket closure rate, team did well in April as per their ticket closure rate. Everyone was above the benchmark. She would see a few at the target. So as per the ticket closure rate, I don't see any major issues. We did good on.
They could resolve it.
Too many questions.
Nope.
Yeah.
Very, by the way, I really like your shirt.
Okay.
Check design, so you and Vishal, you both have.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Check design as for the shirt, so it's like, so the reason I'm saying this because you're on my screen, it just like stands out.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm standing out to you, sorry. And my half-bald head probably too, so sorry about that.
No.
Yeah.
Oh.
No, no, you're doing good. Thanks. OK, getting into the end user sentiment, these are the end user reviews that the team received, and there were a plethora of more which we couldn't fit on the slide, but happy that overall team.
Yeah.
has been doing an amazing work.
All right, we can move on to the next piece, which is the holiday schedule. I know the next one is on May 25th. Tom, as per my understanding, no one is working.
Am I right?
No one from your team is working.
Okay, so...
Bryan, Rico, I mean, see, do you need Rico?
Yeah, well, Rico on Monday. So just for our holiday. Is that what you're sorry, Kevin? Are you talking about? Yeah. Yep.
Yeah, yeah. So that's why I'm just confirming right now that who all need like our team to support business on Memorial Day. So New York, I think there's no one from New York. So I think from St. Louis, we will have Rico work on 25th and who sir works on 25th, we will give them a compost.
Yup.
Yeah.
OK.
So Rico will check.
New Mexico, we need to check with Pat, then Kansas will check if Matthew is needed or not.
So Raida, if you can just make a note, we need to just confirm even though from US perspective, from Philippines perspective, I think.
We are close right on 25th.
And Andy.
Yes, yeah, we are.
OK, so we we need to check then, OK.
Okay, great.
I think instead of that, was it Andrew already?
I'm not sure, Ayra. Did we send it any communication to Pat around New Mexico team? They they need.
No.
Team on 25th.
Yeah, I did ask. I did ask Andrew and he's still checking. He agreed last week, but then the CA and pod asked them to work.
Yeah.
OK, so they're working.
He's still checking. Andrew's still checking with them.
Okay, yeah, no worries. Yep, so we just need to make sure that team is on standby just in case if we need to cover business, then we'll do it.
Yep, I think.
Do.
All right, getting into build it. I believe Larry, you're coming to build it along with Tom, which I doubt.
Yes.
Yeah, good try. Nice try.
Yeah.
Excellent.
Guys have been after me for four years to go to this thing.
See.
So this is why I'm saying Larry is here so we can get you on board.
Yeah, when is this one? August. Oh, I don't know.
If, if I would, I would be happy to go, I would be happy to go if we don't have to write a check. I mean, that's, that's my, that's my fault.
Here's the thing, there's this BOGO offer that's going on, 1 + 1, so you can come along if Larry is coming.
Okay.
Ha ha ha.
I could be Larry plus one, is that it? I'll be Larry's plus one, is that it?
Okay.
That's something that Len needs to decide. If he wants you or maybe Kris.
Yeah, our our deal is buy our our deal is buy zero get 2 free is I thought it was. That's there's no such thing as MOGO.
Yeah, there you go. That's right.
You.
We can definitely look into that as well, Larry. So, you know, Lee.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, Lee's going to bug me about it. I missed the last one. I missed the last one and Lee's going to bug me about it. So I did tell him that I would try to make a point to make one of these. So maybe this one works since it's August. I've got like almost two full months before it comes around. So yeah, I'll have to bug Lee about this one.
Listen, I would love to come.
Absolutely, he will.
I'm telling you right now.
Okay.
Yep.
Just.
And don't worry about the budgets.
I would love to go. I used to work in Jersey City. It's a great town.
Yeah.
There you go, yeah, and...
pass your pass your message to Lee that you know this is by zero get to. I'm sure he's going to do something for you Larry.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah. Leo's got it covered. He's a good deal. He'll get us, he'll get us covered.
List.
Okay.
Awesome. All right then, we can move on. So this time around, we will be covering AI by Design on August 5th. So this is included within the Build It, so it's going to be even better.
It.
All right, uh...
Larry, I'll get in touch with my CX team and you know, because agenda is defined for this, you know, build it. So I think this will be really interesting if you just want to go through the agenda. This is really, really good. Primarily focuses on AI. So we'll share those documents with you and if you find it interesting, definitely we would love to see you over there.
Mm.
You went full IT solution team, yep.
Yeah.
Yeah, please do. It's always stuff that's interesting minimally to us. And it's probably a lot of the things we all say, hey, that would be great if we could get that. So maybe if we all push the right direction, we might get a little help there. So anything you can send, please don't ever hesitate to send things. I like to at least look at it.
K.
Kip.
Sure, will do.
Perfect.
OK.
Thank you, Vishal. Thank you, Larry. Moving on, Team GPS. We all know about Team GPS. I'm going to move on to the next one, which is our way forward. Well, we just want to make sure that we cover Stellan and Nixon as well as per their network training. So Chris, that's our next phase as we decided.
Up.
We will not pull both of them out. We'll just do one by one. Okay, so since Nathan just completed, we're going to push with Nixon first and then maybe Stella. Which one ever works? We'll connect with you separately on this. Okay.
Sounds good. Thank you.
All right, and the team remains focused as per achieving their KPIs. And as per 2026, we just want to make sure that we are delivering the best product possible and we're ready to support ITBD solutions as per their business needs. So that's something we have in store as per the way forward. And with this, I'm going to stop sharing my screen.
Mm.
I will go around the table. Any questions, concerns, or feedback? I'll start with you, Tom, first, because you were the first one who joined along with Ryan. Ryan is second.
Yeah, I listen, I've always I think I think most of the guys are doing well, particularly Ralph and Kyle.
Okay.
I have no complaints whatsoever. I'm pretty happy with the team right now. You know, we had a little, a few bumps in the road, I guess, with Nathan there for a while, but I think he's starting to get the idea, hopefully. But I'll defer to Chris on that one and Taraz if he has any other comments.
Mmh.
Yep.
Sure. Appreciate it, Tom. Thank you. Bryan, over to you.
Rico's been improving, doing a good job. We've been flexing them out to the west, so we're seeing improvement. He's helping out in St. Louis as well, too. And then he's been working on just getting that utilization up, which he's been doing a good job on. So, yep. So, been happy.
Yeah.
Awesome. Awesome. Thank you. Thank you, Ryan.
You're welcome.
Javid.
Nothing but good things to say about Kyle and Ralph, you know, wrestling, you know, good communications, professional, you know, clients are generally happy with them. So just doing a great job.
Awesome. Thank you, David.
Yeah.
Kris, over to you.
Yep, so as Tom mentioned, Nathan has been improving on his communications. The only thing I will say is, and this goes for the whole team, I'm sure Larry's not going to like this, but I don't really care about admin time as much. So we had a few issues where they were just grabbing as many tickets as they possibly could and then stocked
Good.
compiling them. So this way they can work on it and fill in their time sheets. But my concern with that is that they take 5 tickets and by the time they get to the 5th ticket, the person is now annoyed that they had to wait an hour and a half to get service. So my priority and my care is that the client gets quick service and good service, not so much about
the amount of time you have in a time sheet. If you have admin time and you're making it productive admin time, I'm cool with that. So I did have a conversation with the guys. I think I made it clear to them that I want them only grabbing one at a time and then Austin really should be assigning them tickets if Austin assigns them three tickets at a time because we just have a high volume in the queue.
Mm.
then that's different than them grabbing it themselves. So I just want to bring it to your attention as well. But other than that, everybody's been doing good and still is still a rock star. He's really taken off of RMW and he really saves me over there.
Mhm.
They do.
Awesome. Yep. Thank you, Kris, and...
Gonna say he's gonna save me while you're off for the next two days, too.
Yeah.
Yeah, he's the RMW king right now.
Yes, she is.
Yeah, it is. Thank you.
The.
Yeah, and that's great. I mean, Kris, you put that great. I think I, as much as I care about admin time because it shows some utilization number that I get a little beat up on, understanding how they're working and making sure the client's first, that's the key. So love hearing that. And again, when I hear RMW and I hear PPT, like these are the big guns, right, that you guys are managing. So it's awesome to hear that.
No.
Kip.
that the resources are helpful there on those big accounts. So good stuff.
The.
Yep.
Thank you. So, indirectly, Laroia was, you know, coming to you, but you already spoke about it, so I'm going to skip you then. But thank you so much for your feedback. I appreciate it.
That's OK.
Yeah, no, absolutely. This is good. Like I said, I did want to point out one thing though. I liked that piece. I don't always get time to go look at all the feedback that comes in. So when you have it on the presentation, like if you can make sure include all the ones you get, it's easier for me to look there and grab it than it is for me to try to find it in my system. So.
Yeah.
Mm.
Okay.
I appreciate that you do that, so thank you.
You're welcome. You're welcome, Larry. We just want to make sure that we keep on.
revisiting and kind of fun. It's like a continual improvement. We just want to showcase whatever team wants to see it. And then if there's anything else apart from this which you feel like we can add to our presentation, we would love to.
Mhm.
Yeah, no, absolutely. Good stuff. Thank you.
Welcome, thanks a lot. Now to my team, Vishal.
Dio.
Yes.
Thank you so much, Kevin. No, I'm good. No complaints. Something on me that I need to share with Larry regarding the build it. Rest on good. Thank you so much, everyone.
Thank you, Vishal. Ayra.
You've been quiet.
Yep, no, we're good. Absolutely good. But then I'm just waiting for Andrew to confirm since he's not here on the call.
Okay, no worries. Yeah, just let us know if you need help and we can, you know, coordinate. I think.
Yeah.
Will do. Thank you.
Alright, Andy.
Although, nothing really. Great job to everybody. Just following up, Larry, probably to the email that I sent you, the profiles. If you get the chance to review them, let me know.
Yeah, we had a, we're having a little bit of a shift of things with the change with Leah. So as that happens, probably Tom, I'm having discussions between Tom and Steve Getty, one of my other SDMs, about how we're going to shift some resources. So
Mhm.
Mm-hmm.
That actual opening may shift to Tom or to Steve, depending on what we determine internally. So as soon as I know that, but keep sending them and I'll work with Steve and Tom until we know who's going to actually do the kind of role, validating the resumes and such.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
Okay, but keep them coming. And again, like, I know I don't have a whole lot of openings right now, but things are kind of fluid here. So if you've got things and you think, hey, this is a great person, you know, don't hesitate to kind of hang on to them or throw them our way and we'll take a quick look at them.
A
Mhm.
And I know that I'm doing a whole lot more involvement on the managed services side. So I'm taking over a lot of the contracts that we all deal with here. So I'm starting to look at just a bit more at that and understanding where other roles may come into play. So just be aware, I might send them your way.
Uh-huh.
quicker and look to try to quickly turn things around. I think there's other places in the business that would be helpful to have you guys engaged with. So just keep that in mind.
Yep.
Cool, good to hear. Yeah, if you need more profiles other than the two that I sent you, you let me know and then I'll send you a new batch.
Absolutely.
Yep.
Yeah, yeah, give me another day. I just, I got a chance to talk to Steve earlier today. So I just need to circle back. Tom and I need to find some time to circle back and then we'll figure out what that next step is. And that'll determine who's going to look at those and who's going to make that next step of getting that person in front of us.
Mhm.
Oh.
Cool. Gotcha. Thanks.
But it should turn around very quickly as soon as I get a chance to meet with Tom. This is the first time I think I saw Tom this week.
PH.
All right.
We, we, we have our chat later, so I got you.
Yes, yep.
Okay. All right. Appreciate that. Thanks, Larry. But yeah, that's it for me. Thanks, Cohen.
Yeah.
Yep.
Awesome.
Thank you. Thank you, Andy. Well, the only person that's left is Manish. Manish.
Thank you, everyone. Yeah, thank you, Cohen. So, nothing from my side. How I, it's good that engineers are doing good. That's what we are here for. So, do let us know in case anything comes up and we can look into that part. Thank you for your time. That's all I can say right now.
Yeah.
Everyone will shine. All right, with this, that's it from my side. We give you 10 minutes back. Enjoy your time, and we'll speak to you next month. Till then, have a good one. Take care, everyone. Thanks A lot. Everyone.
All right. Thanks, folks. Have a good day.
Have a good one, guys. Bye, guys. Thank you, Javid. Bye bye.
Thanks, everyone.
Bye.